it I don't need karate I can earn a lot
of money I can enjoy my life I can party
do all the bad stuff and subhanAllah I
almost quit sports because none of us
did the same tattoo in the same place
and we paid a lot money for that and one
day the shaitan put the idea in our
heads so let's go and let's do the
tattoo yeah we wanted to do the chemical
there's people who paid in advance
I returned their money say them sorry I
cannot do that
I know team and after that one week I
tore my left ACL first of all the girl
that was tattooing told us that it will
be primary that will not stay permanent
yeah but it's to him till now it didn't
fade away so now you made you went into
the tattoo business now you start yeah
yeah it was like fun it was something
that we wanted to do in ourself but in a
couple of weeks it started to be a big
business the people are coming and
paying me to do that advice the one of
the best soldiers of Shaytan it's the
one who said do it later yeah I know so
subhanAllah don't wait don't wait one
second just like the rental car you
can't start like you know tinting it out
how you want you know putting graffiti
on and stuff yeah what about our body
assalamualaikum guys how you doing it
greens a piece in Bosnia and I'm with
the person was known as the Bruce Lee
from the Balkans
I'm so excited when I see young brothers
who are practicing the Deen and they're
they've been exposed to all of the
temptations of the dunya they had the
dunya but now they're giving it up
for something even greater get ready to
meet my brother Matty's mova CH here on
the D show or anyone
[Music]
brother how you doing
pilot from sellout of intellicus song
the love brother
so they give you the nickname the brew
sleeve of the Balkans mmm I will I
wanted to change it a little bit yeah
the bearded Bruce Lee maybe sounds like
oh that's close sounds good the bearded
Bruce Lee so you've been you've been
involved now you're well established
world champion in in karate and tell us
some what some of your background in the
industry in this martial art of Shotokan
Karate tell us a little bit about what
you do and your accomplishments in the
karate field arena I'm now the four-time
in the role the best sports
art-lete in the sorry abou city
I was two-time the best athlete in the
bosnia-herzegovina I'm basically doing
karate for all of my life from the
childhood till now have more than 300
medals maybe more than 400 I cannot
remember the younger ones but the ones
that are important are in the seniors
when I started to compete over 80 years
18 years older I wind to European medals
individually in 2014 and 2016 one was
bronzed and the other one was silver
I was the World Cup champion 2016 also I
went three or four more with the team we
was 2013 European champion for the
cities we were second on the european
championship with the team so basically
the
those are the biggest achievement
achievement also the Premier League's
and rankings last year I was in top ten
in my category in the world with
rankings and the competition for the
points in ranking their World Cup World
Cup competitions and only 64 competitors
from the world can enter it and compete
on that those competitions so III think
it's common usually you're an athlete
now and you're in the best shape of your
life you're feeling great you're
compressing so much now there's another
side to that you know doors started
opening up young man he starts wanting
young women he starts getting invited to
certain events right sometimes even
training gets compromised a person's ego
gets very big right money gets put on
the table just the whole new world opens
up you kind of got also pulled into that
a little bit and I hummed it a laugh you
got out of that but what was the
transition like from being also in that
arena now and now also those temptations
you know pulling you in luring you in
and then coming to overcoming that and
being where you are today here on the
Dean show that's holla it's a little bit
hard to think about those days in
jahiliyyah
but it's just you know when you're young
and I don't want to say famous but
well-known in your city and when you
started to do all the bad stuff back in
the days we thought it was good and it
was enjoyable and it was cool so I did
to do all the stuff that young people
does except the drugs of course because
of the sports didn't let me to do that I
party a lot I drink a lot especially
offseason where I didn't have
competitions or after the
certain event when I win it is that is
that is that something that was common
like it's normal it's common it's yeah
if you don't do it you're like not cool
you're not cool yeah and you're not that
guy so even if you're like the one guy
that's kind of like you know it's trying
to be because I would imagine you come
in and you're like hold on I got to stay
focused my training but not everyone
else is drinking do you get because of
the peer pressure the pressure you just
succumb to that and you start also you
know because the friends bad company you
get sucked into it
now I wouldn't say bad companies just
become the company that was the shaitaan
did his stuff you know yeah he just
invited us and we accepted it and all of
us had one one group of friends the team
adrenaline we was doing the extreme
sport and all the adrenaline sports from
parkour freerunning G jumping cliff
diving you name it we did it
and one day the shaitan put the idea in
our heads so let go and let's do the
tattoo yeah we wanted to do the chemical
formula of the adrenaline like the
little agent oohs you know the chemical
stuff and we did and the ten of us did
the same tattoo in the same place and we
paid a lot money for that and when we
get back home first of all the girl that
was tattooing told us that it will be
primary that will not stay permanent
yeah but it's to him till now I didn't
fade away and they told me marries what
do you think about it to do tattoos for
us and on us and on yourself as well and
I was like okay I did a lot of artwork
when I was younger in primary school in
high school with with the hip-hop
culture
the graffiti started and I was the
little bit into it and I like to write
and everything that has to do with art
so I accept it why not we order it
waited couple days to get the shipment
from the eBay and we just started you
made it into it so now so now you made
you went into the tattoo business now
you start yeah yeah it was like fun it
was something that we wanted to do in
ourself but in a couple of weeks it
started to be a big business the people
are coming and paying me to do the
tattoos and it took maybe almost three
years and you can imagine in three years
how much the tools that I did run a lot
but now now but now one thing that we
learned is that there's no such thing
because you thought that this would
disappear after three to five years
that's what you were told
yeah so that wasn't true no it's not so
you guys learn a lesson here yeah I hope
you listen I often look I also make an
example when you when you rent a car
right this vehicle this blessing that
the Creator has given us I mean we are
responsible for it it's an Amana and a
trust
just like the rental car you can't start
like you know tinting it out how you
want you know putting graffiti on and
stuff yeah what about our body you know
what I mean the gift that the Creator
has given it to us so but but the thing
is when you don't have that moral
compass the blueprint for life then
everything's open right for
experimentation and try out this try out
that is it's just imagine in Bosnia but
maybe 20 year old guy who is earning
maybe 200 tourists a day yeah with the
Haram business but back in the days I
was not thinking about it as I'm
thinking it now so Hindu light takes God
for the for the straight path yes and I
was learning a lot of money even in one
point I went I was thinking okay I'm
doing karate when I win the medal I get
a little like award from the government
or from the city but that that it cannot
cover even the supplements that I'm them
that I'm drinking to do during the
training season so I was thinking why
should I do karate
I'm
here money I don't need karate I can
earn a lot of money I can enjoy my life
I can body do all the bad stuff and
subhanAllah I almost quit sports because
of you you went really deep into you
know exploring and following one's lost
passions and desires that you almost
even gave up the career successful
career in karate huh and in all of that
in 2014 after winning the first European
medal on my first European Championship
because because of the political
situation in National Federation I was
not giving a chance until from 18 until
20 second year the fourth year I was
doing it like for fun I didn't have
chance to compete for the national team
and when the first time gave me the
chance I win the medal and so plan
allowed a lot outlets are waiting the
whole life to win that that medal and to
retire so I win it on my first
competition for the senior national team
and after that one week I tore my left
ACL III injured my knee hardly I went to
the surgery and have the seven seven
month recovery and after that in that
period the whole business were were you
know I had a lot of free time I was not
training two times because of the injury
so the business grew up I even started
to employ people in my studio because I
could not do it all all by myself so it
was becoming very successful your tattoo
parlor as we call yeah so in 2016 when
Lalaji allah gave me the barakah in the
carotene after the injury and after the
recovery after I returned to the
competitions I was given a chance one
more time and I win the second year
Olympic medal and that was the day when
I know not Olympics Walla inshallah I
will win the Olympic one the european
medal and that was the
that I said to myself that's it no more
Haram business for you from this day
inshallah you will start to change
ourselves so you got out now you left it
yeah I had I had the one-month
appointment in front from the people and
there's the people who paid in advance
I returned their money say them sorry I
cannot do that I just quit it I gave up
from that the all the equipment that I
had I sold after I figure out that I
should not sold it but Hana lights did I
was really limited with with the
knowledge of the of the Deen soap I gave
up from everything and I read somewhere
when if when you left go something in
the name of Allah SWA knowit Allah he
will replace it with something better
and it just happened it happened to me a
couple of months I started to work as a
trainer in the club I get the three or
four groups that I'm training the kids
after couple months I get the Olympic
scholarship half year later I was
invited to go to the Olympic program in
Tokyo the Special Olympic program to
prepare for the Olympics so Subhan Allah
Allah Allah replace it with something
much much better so you saw this
actually come to a reality now yeah this
actually happened you left something for
your Creator you started to live a
morally upright life you connected with
the one who created you living Islam so
now what do you tell your friends who
say now we can't give up you know the
dating of girls we can't give up you
know the partying the drinking it's not
possible you're a living example now
that it is no it's of on lights possible
it's just the way how I started to
practice the religion you know the
people start to pray and then quit you
know the the sea
the the big since they stopped drinking
your son I first stopped to do
everything that is bad I first stop
tattooing then stopped drinking alcohol
and partying then sub dating girls then
all the since when I felt that I'm a
little bit terrified I started with the
five Salah alhamdulillah from the day
when I started until now I didn't miss
one and I feel great and I'm so much
nots a better person but I'm patient I
was never a bad person like evil person
old or thinking somebody bad or do
something bad just dunya is not my
priority yeah I'm preparing myself for
da Hara and from the lights
it's from the day on every day learning
as much as I can you know I started to
learn Arabic Arabic letters the Sephora
in year back so it didn't took me along
Ya Allah Allah Allah gave better can
everything that's that's good that's
that's amazing to see and like when we
talk about give up drinking I mean you
got hundreds of drink you want protein
shakes
go ahead when I smoothie go ahead
vegetable just go ahead I'd recommend
staying away from soda pause because you
know health reasons but alcohol I mean
you know every ten seconds someone is
dying from alcohol consumption so you
give up that we talked about women I
mean come on man this is a protection
from women because what our boy on the
what are the minds of men just to use an
abused woman is that right you know so
it's Larsen so now what is it now you
those are somebody's daughters and
sisters and yeah yeah so now you married
them right so now you're committed to
marrying a woman and living a morally
upright life and that's all based on the
pure monotheism on the worship of the
Creator not the creation and now that
feeling that you had then you talked
about you a restless anxiety and now you
were talking about what
you have some of this come this Sakina
this piece talk about that before we
conclude it's just my friends know me as
very very temper s'en you know I react
hard and it's just I'm I was explosion I
get angry easily in that anger I say bad
stuff do bad stuff from time to time
harm somebody you know because of the
knowledge of the the martial arts that I
learned humble up from the day that
everything changed and it's just I'm
leaving the better life the calm life
I'm a much how do I say it's just sub or
you know yeah I'm more patience yeah
more patient I I put things I slept one
day and then do something think about it
and then do and then react I don't react
immediately everything that comes to me
I think about it first and then do it
therefore I do it and think about it
later
yeah and also of course regret it so hum
delights is just the thing that it
cannot be explained with the words the
feeling that I'm feeling right now and
it's just the feeling that I want to
feel that the rest of my life and
inshallah die as a Muslim and go to the
Jannah and that our primary goal it must
be our primary goal to prepare for the
Hara and I mean what what's the purpose
of the living if it's not that that yes
deep I mean because all of us at any
moment you have people who are in the
best shape of their lives and they just
drop dead car accident plane
you know heart stops but if you just
live for this transitory life even
people who are just out there you know
at that young age even old people still
in the club right the short-term moments
of some kind of experience of you know
it's like waiting 45 minutes an hour for
that amusement right for the roller
coaster but then what you enjoy for 30
seconds but you're still depressed yeah
you forget about it for a little bit so
you got the nightclub you're hanging out
drinking and this life is ticking going
by but you haven't figured out the
purpose of life you figured out the
purpose of life you're another testimony
example that when you transition from
living according to your nafs your
desires unhappiness restlessness then
transforming your life and now living a
morally upright life according to the
verbatim Word of God the Quran and the
Sunnah now you have that Sakina that
you're chocolatey that peace is that you
had it's a struggle obviously right it's
not just you know a piece of cake but
now you have clarity in life because
you're living purpose what advice do you
have final closing comments you're
you're a success story someone who's at
the pinnacle now insha'Allah God willing
you go to Olympics and win that gold
medal and there's other people who are
kind of you people who you've left
behind but you obviously weren't good
for them you have we have love for all
of mankind what advice do you have for
those people out there who are
struggling against their Neffs their
desires man and women you know and they
see you as a role model what do you say
just it in bosnia-herzegovina
the people they're waiting for their
there you know how do I say they're
waiting for the to get old you know to
start - practicing Islam how do you know
that you will get old how do you know
that you as you told the people are
dying in their best best best life years
or best shapes of their lives the one of
the best soldiers of Shaytan it's the
one who said do it later
ya know so subhanAllah don't wait don't
wait one second
if you can do it now go to message it do
the would do pray just do it just do it
it's I see a lot of people a lot of my
friends and all of they say I have
planned inshallah I will do it next year
next Ramadan after Ramadan everything
goes the same I was like that you know
every Ramadan we fast we pray as much as
weekend as the first day of day it
starts we go to night club
what we do one month of free we drink
with we drink alcohol and party for the
what for what how you are pairing for
one month that you sacrifice yourself
for the Lord
so no subhanAllah don't wait for Ramadan
don't wait for the don't wait one second
just that just that that's my advice and
inshallah in a little of time you will
see that that's the that's the one thing
and that's the thing that it's good for
you
I'm Delilah thank you thank you for
sharing that we're here in Bosnia with
the the new bearded Bruce Lee house that
hung the lights good the bearded like
all right you two need to take the
advice learn grow and you'll get clarity
in life we delivered the purpose of life
and seek to know it from the creator of
life we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you
assalamu alaikum Salaam alaikum